voici bientôt 24 heures qu'un boeing
d'air france est détournée aux dernières
informations il vole vers téhéran et il
aurait été interceptée d'ailleurs phare
deux chasseurs iranien ce détournement a
déjà connu plusieurs péripéties que
thierry calmette va nous détailler dans
un instant je vous rappelle simplement
que ce sont quatre terroristes sans
doute des arabes qui ont pris le
contrôle de l'appareil au décollage de
vienne bien qu'un certain nombre
d'otages était libéré la plupart au
cours des différentes escales du bruit
des tournées à genève à catane et à
damas on ne sait pas avec certitude les
raisons des terroristes certaines
informations indiquent qu'il voudrait
par ce détournement protester contre la
politique de la france au proche orient
je vais pas très convaincant peut-être
vaut-il mieux relier cet événement la
conférence qui s'ouvre à genève sur la
palestine demain le film du détournement
donc tirer calmette le vol 780 d'air
france décolle samedi après-midi
deviennent destination roissy avec à son
bord 114 passagers peu après quatre
hommes armés de pistolets et de grenades
semble-t-il oblige le commandant a posé
son appareil à genève il est 15h30
les exigences des pirates sont vagues
ils ne sont pas identifiés mais il
menace de faire sauter l'avion si le
plein de carburant n'est pas fait
une technique de pointe commenté dès
qu'ils ont évoqués par seulement pas des
revendications de quelque nature que ce
soit n'y en a pas la conférence appelle
à signer avec quelconque événement dans
le monde ni à un record à quel point
gouvernement a seulement après des
négociations difficiles sur l'aéroport
de genève en état de siège
il libère 37 passagers surtout des
femmes et des enfants à 18h16 décollage
la destination est inconnue ce sera tour
à tour sofia puis athènes puis tripoli
mais ces pays refuse l'autorisation
d'atterrir finalement c'est à catane en
sicile pour des raisons humanitaires que
l'italie accepte que le boeing 727 se
pose vers 22h40
l'attitude des pirates se durcit il
menace d'exécuter un passager toutes les
cinq minutes si on ne laisse pas
repartir dures négociations de nouveau
les pirates acceptent de laisser
repartir un certain nombre de passagers
55 dont 17 français
ceux ci seront embarqués à destination
de roissy où ils sont arrivés ce matin
à ce moment là il reste dans le boeing
neuf passagers et 8 membres de
l'équipage retenu par les pirates de
l'air le plein de carburant effet
l'avion décolle une fois de plus pour
damas où il se pose ce matin vers 6
heures
les syriens ont accepté là aussi pour
des raisons humanitaires
l'appareil ne déconnent verte et en
suivant les exigences des pirates mais
tout à l'heure le boeing aurait été
intercepté par deux chasseurs dont on
ignore la nationalité alors qu'il se
dirigeait vers téhéran